let's talk about tucker a little bit
what does he have to do where it's like
something happens and he disappears i
think the tactic that you saw is
remember after that massacre in buffalo
where the guy who was influenced by the
people he said he was influenced by a
long list of people not tucker carlson
right instantly there was an attempt to
put the blood of those people at the
doorstep of tucker carlson the strategy
is to isolate him as this
grave threat that we cannot tarry glenn
beck had a bigger audience at five
o'clock hour then tucker had i mean he
had he was breaking insane amounts of
records and at the peak of his
popularity he was off fox news
because he had become so radioactive to
establishment
uh prerogatives that no
advertiser was willing to touch him and
fox got rid of them i think there's a
line that you can't cross no matter how
large your audience size is and i think
tucker is flirting with that line and
you saw
the kind of
attempt to basically start to say that
he is too dangerous to all on air